[Music]
foreign
calling from Australia it is 3am here
hey so I'm Danny calling in from Germany
I know first of all Matt this is amazing
that you're doing all of this I really
appreciate that you're taking the time
to answer all of our questions hi Xenia
here I am from Manila Philippines
this is archana I'm from India we're
calling in from London today my name is
Anna I'm originally from Mexico based in
Mountain View California so my question
is
hello and welcome to think fast talk
smart the podcast clearly I'm not Matt
Abrahams I'm Jenny Luna the executive
producer for our show and you just heard
from some of our listeners who joined
for the live event last month where we
celebrated our 75th episode of think
fast talk Smart in that live episode
Matt shared communication skills to help
all of us become better more confident
and clear communicators in a minute we
will share those here but you'll also
hear the ask me anything where Matt
answered questions from listeners like
you from all over the world we had
almost 1200 people register we had
participants from all continents except
Antarctica we are incredibly honored and
grateful to you our listeners thank you
for tuning in and thank you for
supporting us now here's strategic
Communications lecture and our host Matt
Abrahams
well hello hello so excited to be here
with all of you and thank you so much to
Jenny for getting us kicked off and for
all of the hard work Jenny does to bring
our episodes to you I am thrilled to
have an opportunity not only to share
some key best practices for effective
communication but to take your questions
so thank you for spending part of your
day with us today and we're really
excited to get going to start I thought
I'd introduce you to some key
communication practices that I think can
really make a difference in helping you
be more confident clear and connected in
your communication
so I'm going to start with advice that
if you're a listener of the podcast you
have heard many times and that is it's
really critical to know your audience it
starts with them many of us make the
mistake when it comes to communication
of starting with what we want to say
rather than thinking about what our
audience needs to hear
so before we do anything in our
communication we have to do some
reconnaissance reflection and research
we have to think about who our audience
is and what it is they need because if
we can make our messaging relevant and
Salient for them they'll listen they'll
learn and they're more likely to act so
there are a few things I want you to
think about the audiences you speak to
first and foremost is their knowledge
level relative to the topic that we're
discussing do they know a lot or do they
know just a little
we've all been in that circumstance
where somebody has talked too high level
or too low level for our knowledge and
it just doesn't feel good if you already
know it then you feel like you're
wasting your time and if you don't know
enough you feel lost and that can be
really disconcerting so we have to think
about knowledge level
we also have to think about attitudes is
our audience likely to be supportive of
what we're saying or perhaps not
supportive and we'll adjust our
messaging depending and then finally we
need to think about points of resistance
or hesitation towards what we're asking
is it that they cost too much money
takes too much time requires too much
change we must focus our messages to
adjust and address the resistance we
have so just like all of our guests
mentioned it's all about your audience
it's not about you it's about them there
are three additional Concepts I'd like
to layer on top of knowing your audience
and the first is making sure that you
have a clear goal for your Communication
in all of my strategic communication
classes I teach at the business school
we really talk about the importance of
having a goal now to my mind a goal has
three major parts it's about information
emotion and action in other words what
do you want your audience to know how do
you want them to feel and what do you
want them to do as a result of your
communication and there's one added
bonus of having a clear goal it gives
you a way to judge and assess the
success of your communication you know
when I go all over the world doing this
work teaching communication skills I'll
often ask people and I'll say how do you
know if your communication was
successful and you know the most
frequent answer I get
I got through it as if survival is the
best metric of success now of course
that's ridiculous the best metric of
success is is your audience leaving
knowing what you want them to know
feeling how you want them to feel and
doing what you want them to do
so once you know your audience you craft
a goal
that goal leads you to structure a
message we need to put our messages
inside a structure our brains are wired
for structure there are lots of
structures you can use and those of you
who've listened for a while know that I
am a huge fan of the what so what now
what structure
there are many structures but this
happens to be my favorite you start by
talking about what it is you're
discussing your idea your belief your
product your service your offering and
then you explain why it's important why
is it important and relevant to the
people that you're talking to and then
finally with the now what you explain
what comes next maybe it's let's have
another meeting or let me show you what
I'm talking about or what questions do
you have so it has momentum built in I
think the what so what now what
structure is so powerful not just for
speaking but for writing you can write
emails in this structure then now what
is the subject line and the what in the
so what are the body of the email
if somebody asks you for your feedback
the what is your feedback the so what is
why it's important and then now what is
what you'd like them to do differently
or continue doing now I want to take a
time out in my classes I call this a
meta moment where we look at what we've
just done I actually used this structure
to teach you this structure and I gave
you some examples of how to use it in
fact everything I've said so far has
been in this structure it's very
powerful now there are other structures
that you can use and I encourage you to
find structures that work well for you
having a structure helps you as a
communicator because it gives you a map
that you can remember and it helps your
audience because it packages things up
in a logical ordered way and that's what
our brains like
so we start by knowing our audience we
then create a goal no field do and then
we formulate a structure for our message
to accomplish that goal for our audience
now once we deliver our message
we next have to think about what happens
when our audience responds and so my
final tip and trick is to leverage
paraphrasing I think paraphrasing is so
important and you hear me in our podcast
episodes trying to practice it
paraphrasing is where you distill down
the information that you're hearing or
reading you want to bring it to its
Essence in other words it's the bottom
line of what you're hearing and this
bottom line allows you then to connect
or question
for what comes next so we don't just
paraphrase to paraphrase we paraphrase
to then move on
so I encourage all of you to think about
paraphrasing and you can practice this
when you're in a meeting and you're not
talking or it's a topic that's not
directly relevant for you be thinking to
yourself as you're listening to others
communicate what's the bottom line
what's the takeaway when you're reading
Something challenge yourself to say
what's the bottom line here by drilling
that just like if you're learning a new
sport it would do the drills in that
sport this trains you to do it well it
really helps you focus
now paraphrasing can be used for many
things one it's a great way to signal
that you're listening and to validate
others so for example if you're talking
and ask me a question I can paraphrase
that question one to validate yes I
heard you thank you but I also validate
the Fidelity or accuracy of what I heard
there's no sense me answering a question
you did not ask so by paraphrasing you
can say yes Matt that's the questioner
no I really meant this
paraphrasing also allows you to think
paraphrasing is what we call a lower
order cognitive skill
what that means is that I can paraphrase
and still be thinking about what I want
to say next so it's a wonderful way to
buy yourself time
and then finally I think paraphrasing is
perhaps the most polite way to interrupt
somebody or to move a conversation
forward we have all been part of
meetings or presentations where somebody
goes on too long and what we really want
to say is please stop or shut up we've
heard enough but that's not appropriate
so what we can do is we can paraphrase
we can highlight something of value or
importance that the person has said name
it maybe even comment on it and then
move on so imagine I'm in a meeting and
somebody in the room is talking too much
and I'm the leader of the meeting I
might highlight something they say I
might say oh cost is really important in
fact Jenny I'd love to hear your
thoughts about cost do you see what I
did there I interrupted the person
validated what they were saying about
cost and then I literally took the
content and moved it to somebody else so
I've just told that person and everybody
else in the room we're moving on so
paraphrasing is a tool for validating
emotions and information for buying
yourself time and for moving
conversation forward
so taken together knowing your audience
having a goal no feel due and building
out a structure like what so what now
what can really help you
make your communication more clear
concise and focused and having the
ability to paraphrase helps you interact
with your audience and move the
conversation or the presentation forward
I truly hope that these skills are
helpful for you and can help you hone
your communication
[Applause]
everyone it was amazing to be live with
our think fast talk smart Community
thank you to those of you who joined us
live and thanks to all of you for tuning
in now I thoroughly enjoyed taking
questions from listeners from all over
the world let's start off with two
questions that directly relate to ideas
from my talk
hi Matt this is Mattel from Switzerland
you know you have shared tons of great
communication advices through think fast
talk smart but what is the worst
communication advice that you have ever
given or received
I I leave the choice to you I'm going to
talk about that I've received now I I
certainly know that I've given bad
advice uh for sure but the worst advice
I have ever received was when somebody
told me to memorize everything that I
was saying and to practice it at twice
the speed that I would normally deliver
it their argument was if you can speak
your talk twice as fast memorized then
you really have it well that just goes
against everything I know to be true and
personally feel comfortable with
memorizing is a huge trap while you
think it's helping you it's actually
working against you because your brain
is focused on what you've memorized so
half of your attention is comparing what
you're saying to what you were supposed
to say so you only have half of your
focus on the actual saying of it and
connecting with your audience and the
same something twice as fast just puts a
barrier between you and your audience
you need to speak at a normal natural
rate so the worst advice I ever received
was to memorize and speak twice as fast
I tried and it was miserable and I
literally right before I had to give the
talk and it's a talk that's out there
you can actually watch it it's a that I
gave I'm not going to name it because I
don't want to offend anybody but I just
said no way I'm going to do this my way
and while the talk might not have been
great I certainly felt much better about
it
thanks everyone as you said this in race
I have called from Bangalore and I'm
very thankful for you uh giving your
time and experience my question is
around you talked about understanding
the audience but if we have to present
to a large audience where you have say
20 50 or say hundreds of people how you
try to understand the expectations or
knowledge or background of such kind of
audience and make your presentation
effective thank you for that question
you're absolutely right when you speak
in front of a large group that's very
diverse and you might not know them it's
really hard to understand everything
about them but that doesn't mean we
shouldn't try so again going back to
this notion of reconnaissance reflection
and research so if you're invited to an
event let's say you're at a conference
talk to the organizers of the conference
what do they know about the attendees do
you know the names of the companies
people are coming from to your
presentation can you do some research on
the companies understand what they think
is important look at the bios of the
people who work at that company use
tools like LinkedIn and Google and other
tools to search up people so there is
some work you can do now inherent in
that question I believe was another
question which is what do you do if the
audience because it's so large is varied
in things like knowledge level or
attitude so some people know a lot some
know a little some are in favor some
aren't what do you do first you have to
really think about who is the target set
among the larger group and if so tailor
your message to that Target group if not
you have to scaffold and build that
information so that people are more on
par especially when it comes to
knowledge so let me give you an example
let's imagine you're in a room it could
be a large audience a smaller audience
and you know some people know a lot and
some know a little here's what we know
from research first you should
acknowledge that so when you start you
say in this room we have some people who
know a lot and some who know less
what we know from research is that this
actually bolsters your credibility
people see you as more credible because
you're acknowledging that you've done
some homework and you know who's there
the second thing you should do is let
people know that you're going to spend
the first few minutes of your talk of
your presentation of the meeting
upholding or building some foundational
skills and then you'll get to the deeper
level this does two things for you the
people who don't know a lot are very
thankful because you're going to help
them learn and for the people who do
know a lot you just told them that they
have to wait just two or three minutes
to get through that rudimentary stuff so
they're going to stick with you if you
simply start with the foundations and
the basics the people who know a lot are
going to check out so we do have to
spend time we might use technology we
might ask people who can help us to
figure out who's in the room and if
there's some variation we can work hard
to figure out how to scaffold that
information thank you for that question
we also had some practical questions
about how others see us in general and
in interviews here are the questions and
math thoughts
my name's Anish I'm calling from the UK
my question was basically how do I
communicate negative feedback to a
colleague especially when there's an
action step involved as I say if
something needs to be done urgently but
I don't want them to take offense to
negative feedback or start an argument
or anything like that excellent thank
you Anish for the question and thank you
for calling in all the way from across
the pond so feedback is a really
challenging situation especially when
it's constructive or critical my
perspective is that feedback is actually
an opportunity to problem solve so what
you're trying to do in the initial
giving of the feedback is to invite the
other person to collaborate with you we
want to avoid defensiveness in a lot of
times we come from a place of
frustration of high emotion because the
person isn't doing it right whatever
right is or they've messed things up and
we need to distance ourselves from that
emotion maybe take a walk around the
block talk to a friend write out how
you're feeling but try to put those
emotions not away but under control
and then think through what is the best
way that I can invite this person to
actually interact on this topic so
rather than coming at somebody and
saying you messed up and you're doing
this which can make people defensive you
might want to phrase it as questions and
say I've noticed a few times that this
is what I see how can we work together
too so by making the feedback an
invitation it reduces defensiveness and
invites collaboration now certainly
there are times where feedback must be
direct must be specific and you need
people to stop things right away that's
not where you ask a question but there
are many times where thinking through
our emotion
thinking through what might be
motivating the behavior and then finally
focusing on how to ask as a question
your feedback so that you can invite the
people in can be really really important
to you thanks for that question Anish I
hope there was some value in that I'd
love to hear some more questions thank
you I'm pranav I'm calling from India
Bengaluru they say first impression
lasts and how would you make your first
impression some say start with a story
some say start with the humor some say
start with a quote and which how would
we know that who would receive it better
which one would be the better way to
start your speech or
some addressing That You Gotta Give so
so you're absolutely right first
impressions are important they they
anchor future Impressions it doesn't
mean you can't change what people see of
you or how they think but it's a bit
harder so so to be thoughtful about how
to come across when people first meet
you or when you first start a
communication it's pretty important
now the question of what's the best way
you know my MBA students get very
frustrated with me because I get a lot
of questions like this and my answer is
always it depends it depends on what you
know about your audience if I'm speaking
to a very technical data-driven audience
it might be in my best interest to
establish a good connection and a good
first impression to use some data it
might be if I'm speaking to a general
audience that's starting with a story or
telling a joke might make the most sense
so so we start with what we think will
resonate best with the audience what
their expectations are and what will
connect the second part of that is
what's authentic to yourself right if
I'm not comfortable telling stories or
trying to be funny to Simply tell a
story and to be funny because I think
that's what's going to help my audience
see me well sets me up for for bad
outcomes so start with what you think is
important for the audience and try to
conform to that and then think about
what's authentic and true for you
and I encourage all of you as a third
bit of advice to practice and test
things out
so if you're giving a big presentation
or facilitating a big meeting think of
two or three different ways to start and
see how that resonates test it with
other people practice it and see how it
sounds and that's going to help you
what I will tell you is this and and
anybody who knows me has heard me say
this my biggest pet peeve the thing that
bothers me most about all communication
is how people start meetings and
presentations
I think it is a bad idea and just plain
ridiculous to start presentations and
meetings by starting with hi my name is
and today I'm going to talk about boring
but now and often really silly because
I'm in front of a slide that has my name
and the title of my presentation or
somebody has an agenda that says the
same thing I think you should start all
your communication just like action
movies start how do action movies start
with action
ask a question tell story take a poll
then introduce yourself how would your
favorite action movie Whatever It Is
feel if when you were watching it it
started with the title and the credits
and then the action came it would be a
very different experience than the way I
bet your favorite action movie started
with some kind of action and then they
told you who was in the movie and what
it was so first impressions matter jump
right into it rather than then ease your
way in with some kind of Preamble and I
think that's going to help you the best
our final question came from a
father-daughter pair and addresses
virtual communication
it's actually my daughter Maddie's
question just my computer okay well
where are you and Maddie calling in from
Jackson Hole Wyoming oh beautiful
location what's your question Maddie
um has the Advent of zoo meetings change
your approach to communicating in
Virtual groups absolutely
virtual communication whatever tool it
is Zoom team meets WebEx you name it has
it has changed many things about the way
we communicate now some things stay the
same you should know your audience you
should have a goal you should leverage
structure but a couple things become
even more important let me name them the
first is being concise
virtual communication has mandated that
we be more concise and clear why people
are more easily distracted and as many
of us learn during the pandemic we can
cram in more communication in a day many
of us had many more meetings and did a
lot more communicating when we were in
the pandemic so you have to be more
concise and clear
the other thing that virtual
communication has mandated is we have to
be more engaging when we're physically
in a room together or sharing the same
space I can read cues and clues from you
that I can't when we're virtual so that
means I have to manufacture
opportunities for me to see if you're
tracking if you're interested if you're
engaged so I might use some of the tools
that something like Zoom or teams
provides like I'll take a poll I'll have
you use the chat I might use a shared
whiteboard these are all engaging
techniques so I can get information that
if we were in person I could read just
by watching what you pay attention to
and how you respond so so Maddie it it
has dramatically changed the way we
communicate yet some of the things still
remain the same and the reality is this
virtual is not going away we're going to
be more hybrid which I think is even
more challenging where you've got some
in the room and some on the zoom room
and you have to balance that out but
this the ideas of trying to be engaging
more clear and concise still remain
[Music]
wow great questions and a great
experience thanks again to all of you
who joined us live and a big thank you
to all of you who are listening in now
we are always excited to hear from you
we have several ideas of how we will
connect and interact in the near future
for now please register for our think
fast talk smart the newsletter by going
to stanford.io slash TF TS newsletter
follow us on Instagram Twitter and
Linkedin and please invite your friends
family and co-workers to listen in
[Music]